[Musica]
io sono qui oggi perché vorrei
condividere con voi un tema che
estremamente attuale e che credo che ci
traghetterà direttamente verso quella
che jeremy rifkin definisce la terza
rivoluzione industriale
parlo della della novità del fatto che
da oggi tutti noi possiamo installare
impianti per la produzione di energia da
fonti rinnovabili sulle nostre case e
condividere vendere questa energia ai
nostri vicini di casa è una rivoluzione
epocale e prende il nome di comunità
energetica
cosa sono queste comunità energetiche
sostanzialmente sono delle comunità che
sono costituite da dei consumatori
quindi possono essere cittadini imprese
enti pubblici che si mettono assieme
producono energia elettrica fatte in
casa qui da fonti energetiche
rinnovabili e massimizzano l'autoconsumo
e l'autosufficienza energetica
all'interno della loro comunità quanto
più sono bravi autoconsumare essere
autosufficienti
tanto più ricevono degli incentivi
quindi quanto più se entriamo in
simbiosi con i nostri vicini di casa con
l'azienda che rinfrancano è tanto più
noi veniamo premiati e questa è una
rivoluzione importante
i membri delle comunità energetiche
acquistano anche un nome vengono
chiamati prosumer produttori e
consumatori di energia e entrano a far
parte del mercato elettrico diventano
dei veri operatori del mercato elettrico
quindi acquistano ruolo importante anche
all'interno punto del della società e
perché nascono le comunità energetiche
nascono da un'idea della commissione
europea
abbiamo appena sentito la presidentessa
della commissione europea che parlava
del del ruolo forte che l'europa nella
lotta al cambiamento climatico l'europa
è leader nella lotta al cambiamento
climatico in europa e noi facciamo parte
di un europa che ha una visione
assolutamente sostenibile del nostro
futuro e sta cercando di traghettare
tutti i paesi membri verso la
transizione
e c'è una visione particolare rispetto
alla produzione e consumo di energia
elettrica
veniamo da un modello centralizzato dove
abbiamo grandi impianti a gas oa carbone
che producono energia elettrica e questa
energia viene portata nelle nostre case
attraverso grandi infrastrutture
riprodotti ad altissima tensione poi ad
alta tensione e media tensione fino alla
bassa tensione nelle nostre case
bene adesso il modello è stato cambiato
totalmente è questa questa soluzione non
è più sostenibile questa architettura
passiamo da un modello centralizzato un
modello decentrato piccoli impianti che
producono energia da fonti rinnovabili e
forniscono energia alle comunità che
l'auto consumano riducendo al minimo
l'utilizzo della rete che dell'energia
elettrica che viene fornita dalla rete
quindi diventando autosufficienti bene
questo è veramente un cambiamento
epocale verrà rivoluzionato tutto il
sistema elettrico europeo ma questo
permette anche di avere una riduzione
dei costi in bolletta perché noi non
dipendiamo più degli investimenti che
vengono realizzati sulle opere e sulle
infrastrutture nazionali quindi pesiamo
meno sulle infrastrutture nazionali
quindi si riduce anche il costo in
bolletta
aumentiamo la produzione di energia da
fonti rinnovabili e soprattutto ci
affianchiamo dalla fornitura di energia
elettrica della rete e aumentiamo la
indipendenza elettrica del nostro paese
dall'acquisto di energia da altri paesi
soprattutto di energia fossile
l'italia produce il 35 per cento
dell'energia elettrica che utilizza che
consuma quindi una quota bassissima
dobbiamo puntare a essere più
autosufficienti dal punto di vista
energetico
queste comunità energetiche sono una
rivoluzione sull'innovazione sistemica
viene chiamata a un'innovazione
sistemiche come è stata ad esempio il
passaggio dal cavallo all'automobile
hanno innovato questa questa rivoluzione
ha innovato tutto il sistema ci siamo
portati dietro l'innovazione in ambito
legale
un'innovazione in ambito tecnologico non
esistevano le strade prima
dell'automobile non esistevano le
assicurazioni
le aziende che producevano
componentistica esisteva neanche il
codice della strada abbiamo bisogno di
un cambio di sistema si chiama una
transizione da un sistema socio tecnico
economico a un altro le comunità
energetiche si portano dietro una
transizione di tutto il sistema e come
si fa a partire da una da un modello è
arrivare un altro si devono mettere in
pratica delle sperimentazioni che da
progetti pilota poi diventano dei
progetti che sono consolidati quindi e
tante sperimentazioni che cercano di
abbattere tutte le barriere e che si
consolidano nell'economia e nella
società attuale
io ho un progetto che cerca appunto di
portare avanti una sperimentazione sulle
comunità energetiche si chiama jacko è
un progetto che stiamo sviluppando al
pilastro roveri e che è la prima
comunità energetica di quartiere in
italia quindi un progetto sperimentale
che porta avanti una comunità energetica
che parte dal basso coinvolgendo propri
cittadini che sono il motore di queste
comunità energetiche devono avere voglia
di stare insieme e di costituire una
comunità e sono dei partner di questo
progetto siamo agenzia per l'energia di
modena poi c'è anche una lista di
bologna ed enea ed è insieme cerchiamo
di portare faticosamente avanti una
comunità energetica siamo agli inizi
perché la normativa è l'ultimo pezzo
informativo deve ancora uscire diciamo
abbiamo gli incentivi che sono stati
emanati il 15 settembre quindi al 15
settembre abbiamo certezza che queste
comunità energetiche in italia un
sostegno economico ma bisogna definire
ancora alcune procedure poi dopo
possiamo partire diciamo core attuazione
il nostro un progetto che si fonda sulla
prospettiva dell'autoconsumo e di
energia e dell'autosufficienza e abbiamo
anche con approccio sistemico
cerchiamo di sviluppare le entità
giuridica perché le comunità energetiche
sono delle società tra cittadino quindi
io costituisca una società con i miei
vicini di casa
e perché voglio gestire meglio i nostri
processi energetici all'interno della
comunità queste entità giuridiche
sull'entità nuove sono delle società
delle cooperative delle associazioni per
cui dobbiamo definire i contratti e lo
statuto i regolamenti che si danno
queste entità giuridiche dopo di che
dobbiamo definire anche dobbiamo portare
innovazione anche nella parte
tecnologica le comunità energetiche si
portano dietro tantissimi innovazione
tecnologica oltre all impianto per la
produzione di energia da fonte
rinnovabile
abbiamo il tema del dello stoccaggio
dell'energia dei sistemi di accumulo
le batterie sono importantissime perché
le fonti energetiche rinnovabili sono
delle fonti di energia non programmabili
e viene detto che viene fit e non di
spaccia bili perché non non si riescono
a programmare nel tempo a volte c'è
nuvola volte c'è il sole a volte c'è
vento a volte non c'è e quindi deriva lo
scarso utilizzo
la batteria sistema da pupo ci permette
di rendere utilizzabile massimizzare
l'utilizzo delle fonti energetiche
rinnovabili e rendere disponibile
energie l'energia per lunga di consumo
quando ne abbiamo bisogno
un altro tema molto importante è il
tutto il sistema di intelligenza che
vogliamo installare nelle nostre case si
parla spesso di smart building smart
city però nessuno le ha mai viste queste
città smart queste città intelligenti
questi edifici intelligenti bene ora è
venuto il momento di rendere i nostri
diffici intelligenti perché perché
abbiamo un obiettivo monitorare i nostri
consumi per essere autosufficienti
allora abbiamo dei dispositivi che
possiamo installare nelle nostre case si
prende il nome di smartbox e possono
essere collegati a dei sensori ea delle
applicazioni per i nostri smartphone e
controllare la gestione delle energetica
nelle nostre case
così come possiamo avere dei sistemi di
monitoraggio che installiamo sui nostri
contatori che dialogano con gli smart
box e rendono flessibile la produzione
di energia dai pannelli
e il consumo che abbiamo all'interno
delle nostre case
riusciamo anche a fare delle analisi
predittive dire fra tre giorni ci sarà
il sole e faccio la lavatrice fra tre
giorni piuttosto che farla oggi che
piove quindi la tecnologia è
importantissima un altro elemento molto
importante è la parte sociale la parte
sociale credo che sia la parte più
importante della cometa energetica siamo
noi come cittadini primi che dobbiamo
cambiare i nostri stili di vita i nostri
le nostre abitudini far parte della
comunità energetica significa acquisire
un ruolo diverso ci chiamiamo prosumer
dentro la comunità energetica ma
iniziamo a gestire una società quindi
diventiamo anche imprenditori e iniziamo
a darci delle regole che decidiamo noi
la comunità energetica ricevere gli
incentivi per l'energia autoconsumata ma
come poi questi incentivi questi questi
benefici economici vengono reinvestiti
sulla comunità lo decide la comunità
stessa il regolamento solo dalla
comunità si può scegliere di dividere
gli incentivi in base a quanto ho avuto
consumato si può scegliere se dividere
gli incentivi in base all'area
millesimale alla disputa della grandezza
della casa si può decidere di
distribuire incentivi perché ci sono
famiglie fragili nella nostra comunità e
quindi l'ora nella precedenza o può
anche essere che l'impianto della
comunità energetica installato sulla
scuola e cittadini decidono di lasciare
questi questi benefici economici alla
scuola per comprare e
materiale didattico per i ragazzi quindi
la comunità energetica
cosa fa torna riporta dei benefici
economici che attualmente sono lasciati
altri paesi perché la produzione di
energia e delle produzioni fonti fossili
avviene all'estero non in italia quindi
attualmente tutto il valore economico
dell'energia non lo vediamo noi quindi
produrla poco a dire portare quei
benefici economici della produzione
energetica significa che noi investiamo
sul nostro territorio questi benefici
economici è insegnamento importante con
jacko siamo agli inizi e speriamo di
partire entro fine anno quei primi
impianti abbiamo diversi soggetti che
sono interessati a partire alcuni sono
centri commerciali
alcuni sono residenziali abbiamo
l'obiettivo di coinvolgerli tutti perché
tutti devono far parte del di questa
rivoluzione io credo che oggi giorno e
la comunità energetica non sia più una
scelta e la comunità energetica è
un'opportunità e che ci viene data ma
un'opportunità importante per diciamo
cambiare e introdurre nuovi metodi nuovi
modelli di auto consumo e di consumo
collettivo abbiamo dei modelli nuovi che
ci possa aiutare a cambiare i nostri
comportamenti e soprattutto abbiamo la
possibilità di andare a rigenerare anche
le nostre città grazie a questi nuovi
modelli di comunità energetica
un tema molto importante è anche quello
che il la comunità di per sé parte dal
dall'energia quindi da una gestione
energetica della comunità però con
ricadute anche su altri temi
la comunità ha spirito di comunità in
questo momento storico diciamo del che
stiamo vivendo di crisi sanitaria
economica e l'aver una comunità viva
efficace che ci aiuta a gestire anche le
problematiche estremamente importante
io ora vi lascio con una
mele di una di una persona che c'è
scritto che abita in provincia di monza
e che è disponibile a trasferirsi al
quartiere pilastro
e perché ha saputo che qua c'è una
comunità energetica quindi ci sono
persone che sono pronte a trasferirsi a
venire a vivere in altri contesti perché
hanno deciso che vive una comunità
energetica un valore e loro vogliono
perseguire questa questo valore questa
idea questi modelli perché sono più
sostenibili e perché ci permettono di
garantire un futuro anche ai nostri
figli
[Applauso]